now I read your column yesterday I loved
it Mohammed on grease right so you
talked about Oh are we now heading into
a grexit I grax it in for a Christian
and you were gaming this out you were
saying look there's a forty five percent
chance we might see some sort of messy
compromise there's a ten percent chance
we'll actually see a meaningful
breakthrough and now a forty five
percent chance that Greece might
actually exit the euro so how did you
come to that letter conclusion yeah and
that's a big change in the past it was a
question of grexit versus muddle through
and hopefully make it now there's a real
chance of an accident and what I mean by
an accident is that Greece ends up
exiting not because someone makes a
formal decision not because Greece makes
a formal decision or Germany makes a
formal decision but rather because it's
pushed out as happened in Argentina in
december 2001 when it was pushed out
with dollar peg now why is that
happening first they are losing the
structural holders of their paper
substance examples and bloomberg has ran
we legal stories on this subsidiary's of
greek bank abroad have got the top of
the shoulder saying sell your Greek
bonds bank depositors are increasing
their withdrawal of money the ECB is
getting more nervous about the emergency
liquidity assistant that is providing
with so that less liquidity is getting
sucked out of the system I think you
already saw they put their hands i
decree on the money of local governments
the next issue is going to be domestic
iou's and at some point the falls are
going to occur so unless Greece and is
credited strange course fundamentally we
are heading towards an accident which
increasing the probability of exit I do
not believe and this is important I do
not believe that Greece can exit and
stay in the east in the eurozone some do
I don't